[Music]
most people when they think of a jockey
think of a male jockey people who don't
think women can be drunk is uneducated
obviously we're proving ourselves
i've become the first female jockey to
win the melbourne cup
it took 150 years for a woman to finally
win
[Music]
my name is michelle payne and i am a
jockey and horse trainer horse racing
has been part of our family before i was
born my dad was a jockey and a horse
trainer and
my older brothers and sisters all
followed in his footsteps
i was very lucky growing up with a
family where it wasn't ever suggested
that female jockeys couldn't be as good
as the male jockeys and i think that
really helped me
the melbourne cup is the race that stops
the nation it's such a huge event in
australia
as a jockey it's what we all aim towards
from as young as four or five years old
it was basically my dream to become a
jockey and to win the melbourne cup so i
felt very privileged to have been the
first female jockey to win
[Music]
it was a moment of disbelief it was a
moment of years of training and dreaming
of winning our greatest race in
australia it was an amazing feeling
i think the racing industry is great
because men and women compete equally
and there's no separation between one or
the other
in the generation coming through we've
got a lot more female apprentices and i
think that's fantastic what i'd say to
young children who would like to be a
jockey don't let people say you can't
because obviously it is possible that
for me has been the most important part
of winning the melbourne cup showing and
proving to young girls coming through
and current jockeys that it is possible
[Music]
you